hello everyone and welcome to round 2 of
the 2020 candidates tournament it's the
first game to finish and it's top seed
versus bottom seed Fabiano Caruana
versus the wild-card Kiril alex anko now
it's it's a really exciting game again
well I'm not even gonna say that the
preparation that went into the game that
was awesome because every player of
course prepared a lot for this
tournament so let's just dive straight
into it and buy straight into it I mean
let's check out some nice close-ups of
the players courtesy of Lenin totus
official photographer of the fidei
candidates tournament 2020 so here let's
just enjoy this nice close-up of Alex
anko and also here we have a nice
close-up of Fabi making his move grab
grabbing that night as you can see now
let's check out the game so Fabi with
the white pieces opens with beef or with
Knight to f6 by like zinc or c4 e6 and
the knife to c3 inviting to an Enzo and
Alex anko is ready for it he shows that
he is prepared for a fight so Bishop to
b4 the nimzo-indian is on the board and
while there are a lot of different ways
you can treat the names Indian defense
Fabi goes for f3 the commode defense so
fighting for that efore square black
replies the same he also wants to fight
for efore and now a3 asking do wanna
capture on c3 or go Bishop back to e7
now
well capturing on c3 is perfectly fine
and it is in fact the the most common
move in this position Alex ankle goes
back Bishop to e7 he wants to keep
pieces on the board with E for by Fabi
and now D captures on e 4f Capra's on e4
n c5 and we reached the position that we
analyzed not so long ago in January in
the Tata Steel masters additional it is
a future versus Vishwanathan Anand
we're Fallujah prepared this ePHI move
against on and he lost in the end but it
was an extremely complicated game and it
was a beautiful game but it is a you
know a one-trick pony moves so the same
d5 is the move here so this is what Fabi
goes for with it captures and d5e
captors and here are castles and here
Knight f3 is the most calm
move here but Bishop to e2 is what Fabi
goes for our following one of the one of
the games pretty versus not Metallica vs
predicate probably postponing the
development of the night maybe see how
black will continue development not
allowing this instant Bishop to g4 and
okay there is a game we mentioned
Metallica vs spread the word Bishop to
d6 was played and matter who was able to
win that game last year but here we have
looked yet by Alex and Co and it is as
of move 10 that we have a completely new
game so let's see how far we continues
he now goes knife to f3 and of course a
bunch of the g4 now that it is possible
and Fabi castles with Knight B to d7
Alex & Co continues development and now
d6 and these six is not a movie
recommended by the engine it is but some
of the engines lesser line so I think
Fabi prepared this as it's probably the
most difficult and confusing move for an
for a human to deal with so let's see
how Alexei encode deals with it Bishop
goes back to f8 and now if this is a if
this is a strong pond and then that's
great but if it turns out to be a weak
pawn then Fabi might have overreached a
bit with h3 hoping for capture hoping
for characters and characters to get his
light squared bishop on this diagonal
but of course Alex encode the clients
and now Knight B to D 5 once again
defending the pawn but also with ideas
of Knight to c7 so rook the e6 Alex & Co
prevents it because if now a 97 then
Brooke captures comes with an attack on
the Queen and you just pick up the night
so instead or well you just go back
Knight to d5 but then you just lost the
pawn not nothing really going on there
so Bishop to f4 instead strengthening
the d6 pawn and now comes a 6 Alex & Co
invites nice the c7 we have nice the c7
and then now rook to e4 by Alex & Co and
here if Abby didn't spend all that much
time it's possible to capture the route
but if you capture the rook you go into
this rook captures an f4 Knight back to
c7 and now Knight the b6 opening up
discovery and well hoping to win win
this pawn and now after Queen
to d2 going after the rook now he just
straight Queen captures Queen captures
Bishop captures and then out the night
it goes back night here and now you go
Knight captures sea captures and Bishop
to g6 and this is the position that
arises you cannot capture the d5 pawn do
to look to rook a to be won and you
would have some problems here with the
knight and Bishop on the D file but this
is the position you would get where
black is up upon and well it is playable
but not something not something bobbies
interested in so Fabi postpones this and
he keeps the pressure with Bishop to h2
we worked the c8 Alex & Co now gets his
rook to safety and now comes g4 and now
again it's it's a deadly there at to
give Alex a cone he has to decide what
to do the problem is it's not so easy to
decide what to do here for example if
you just move the Bishop Bishop to g6
then the problem is Bishop to d3 and
your rook doesn't really have all that
many squares this is taken this is taken
by the night this is taken by the pawn
so what you could do is go for something
like rook III but then you get into
Bishop captures captures and Queen d2
you again force the rook back and after
rook to e4 now g5 and it's really really
hard to keep control of everything it's
unclear where this night is going to so
let's say 98 now rook fe1 you threaten
the rook and the route cannot move
because the knife hangs on e8 so let's
say captures captures and now again this
is the threat and you don't have good
squares for this night you have to go
for Knight captures on c7 and it's it's
a terrible position for black pawn
captures the Queen has nowhere to go you
have to give up the rook but then why
doesn't even have to capture the rook
white can just go 95 and you will win
the window piece here the knight cannot
move the Queen is under attack and
there's not much you can do whatever you
do you're just gonna bring another piece
in to the attack and that's it you're
gonna play anything and lose let's say
characters capture whoa not that
captures with check the bishop here
captures and then after rook moves let's
say Bishop capture 75 and you end up
being up a piece so those are the
complications that some of the
complications that arise if you just
move
so here Alex ANCA went for Bishop
captures in g4 Knight captures and g4
was a bit more precise but again in this
madness where Alex and cos clock is you
know running down it's hard to decide
not Bishop captures but rook captures a
because of this rook captures would
check you get the rook away from the
from the Bishop Bishop d3 will not come
with an attack on the rock and then
after King moves let's say rook g6 and
now and now you can you can continue
continue playing the game however Alex
and went for Bishop captures and g4
instead and after H captures Knight
captures he decided to go for this
still not rook captures he decided to go
for Knight captures and now Bobby goes
Bishop to d3 and now again you cannot
move the rook because after Luke moves
the bishop to f4 and the rookies out of
squares you will have to give up the
exchange so Alex and Co went for Knight
captures on h2 this way you don't lose
material but you you shouldn't forget
you're already down material you've
sacrificed a piece for the attack Bishop
captures only for biphobia Knight
captures on f1 Queen captures on f1 and
now Bishop captures and e6 grabbing that
d6 pawn threatening to pick up the night
although Knight f6 was a slight
improvement on the position because well
you develop a piece with tempo the
Bishop is under attack you don't have
time for rook to d1 the to strengthen
your pawn or something so you'd have to
defend it or move the bishop and only
then Knight captures rook characters and
Queen captures so it would be it would
be sort of an improvement but still
let's say b5 and you're still down a
piece you're up three pawns but you're
down a piece but it was definitely an
improvement on capturing right away here
Alex and Co captured and now Fabi goes
back Knight to d5 and here we have g6
you have to play it at some point queen
is coming to h3
the bishop already attacking h7 is gonna
be extremely unpleasant and
well just g6 it is the strongest move
recommended by the engine and the Queen
to h3 now by Fabi and here there are
already a lot of very nasty threats for
example the most
this one let's say black isn't careful
starts pushing on the queenside
do you see what what fabi's idea was
here I'm sure you can see it without
even pausing the video so I'm not gonna
ask you to do it
of course Queen captures on these seven
just picking up in the night and if you
capture it in just night of six check
and you win back the piece and you
cannot trap the night because the night
always has a way out be six to d5 let's
say and and so on so Queen h3 really a
deadly threat and here we have King to
g7 not allowing Knight f6 to come with
check and here I will ask you to pause
the video because we are we are looking
at a disgusting engine line and I know
you guys enjoy those so feel free to
pause the video and spot this disgusting
engine line while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who are able
to do this congratulations on finding
the idea that far be missed
and for those who just want to enjoy the
show it's Bishop to f5 now that you see
it of course it becomes clear because
well the knight is under attack you
cannot move the night because the rook
you lose you lose the rook and c8 so
what can you do basically only move is G
captures on f5 and now King f2 and I
know it's a lot to ask for to even
consider something like this you know I
think I can do this tournament but like
I said it's a disgusting any line so I
will show it so tonight a fate preparing
to block the rooks check with Knight to
g6 so rook to g1
Knight to g6 and now Knight to g5
threatening Queen captures on h7 if you
go here then Knight captures and f7 is
deadly and both of the Queen and the
rook urge us to destroy the position so
you have to block with the Queen but now
Queen captures on f5 you attack this
bond so Queen has to go back to defend
it
now you again threaten on h7 h6 now you
have to play it and now Queen to h3
saying that if you capture Queen h7 is
mate the knight is guarding f6 so the
Queen again has to guard it but now
Queen d7 with a double attack on f7 and
on d6 Queen to e8 of course you have to
defend the pawn and the now.just Queen
captures and v6h capture sin g5 you
again grab a piece but now Queen f6
King to g8 and now rooked h6 and
whatever you play here it's simply not
enough Knights that East seven check is
coming not a lot you can do about it if
Knight captures then rook the8 is made
so you will not be able to do that and
if let's say rook c6 you still go Knight
East seven check and now after Queen
captures now you play rook g6 check
I have captures and you pick up the
Queen so a very very simple and easy
yeah not so much so of course if I be
ignored the bishop to f5 he played King
the h1 he made a room for his rook on
the G file and now comes Knight to e5 by
Alex & Co so what do you do here and the
bishop tell five by Fabi wasn't even a
point wasn't even a piece sacrifice
because you were already up a piece so
not really sacrificing anything offering
this trade but now Knight to h4 of
course Fabi wants to bring the rook into
the game and maybe have some ideas of
Knight f5 check and so on so h5 probably
would with the idea that he wants to
create an outpost for the knight on on
g4 but on the other hand it is a further
weakening of the position so rook the g1
by Fabi and now Bishop back to f8 it's
not easy to find the move Alex & Co
tries this one to open up some some
squares for the Queen also the rook can
now help out with the defence but it's
it's a really difficult position so here
Knight characters and g6 or already
seems like a decent idea but Fabi first
prepares it with Knight to f4 so what do
you do here Alex think oh now this going
for Knight to g4 he of course once the
block the rook on the G file but now
Fabi goes for it Knight captures on h5 g
captures on age 5 and now Bishop to f5
attacking the rook and preparing to bust
open the position along the G file so if
you if you try and save the rook then
just captures and captures or even
better with the Queen check now if you
go to have six then you're already just
to running away with the King you will
you will get made it very quickly and if
you go somewhere like this then it's
just check and the mate so also a
possibility so Bishop to e7 was played
trying to give up the exchange but not
just bishop
Sanji for next move you can capture and
see it with a discovered check so H
captures we have Queen captures in g4
with Czech Bishop to g5 blocking and
here fib just played Queen to h5 and it
was in this position on more 34 that
Kira alex angkor resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
let me just check something really
quickly because it's I kind of heard
that maybe even more moves were played
but I will just make sure that I kind of
think that they ended the position here
but I will check once more and sometimes
the interface freezes and it it doesn't
show any more moves but yeah yeah that's
it sorry about that just I just wanted
to make sure Alba dia here he resigns it
because well rookie actress and g5 is
coming not much you can do about this
and if you try something like f6 the
defendant then you're just running into
into will a very quick midnight a5 check
you have to move King the f8 Queen the a
traits checked King to f7 the night
Knights that covers g7 in d7 Queen h7
check King back to f8 and now comes
Queen g7 check you're gonna go King e8
rook to e1 width check and now there is
nothing more to be done here
the King has no squares you can give up
some pieces to prolong the inevitable
but at some point you will have to
succumb to mate so after Queen h5 Alex &
Co resigns and Bobby grabs his first
victory in the feet of candidates
tournament 2020 in round 2 so a great
game and really impressive preparation
by favi Alex angles time was just really
really going down quickly and in in the
end it was just overwhelming so a lot
more has happened already in round 2 and
I know a lot of you know this so we are
continuing with the coverage so stay
tuned I would like to thank Federico and
watch you for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here they will both
be from the candidates tournament if you
missed it
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
candidates and well for now only that so
thank you all I will see you soon and
here have an excellent rest of your day